you stand in the presence of daenerys
stormborn of house targaryen
rightful heir to the iron throne
rightful queen of the andals and the
first men
protector of the seven kingdoms the
mother of dragons
the khaleesi of the great grass sea the
unburnt
the breaker of chains
this is jon snow
he's king in the north
thank you for traveling so far my lord i
hope the seas weren't too rough
the winds were kind you're great
apologies i have a flea bottom accent i
know
but jon snow is king in the north your
grace he's not a lord
forgive me you're grace this is the
davos seaworth
forgive me sir davos i never did receive
a formal education
but i could have sworn i read the last
king in the north
was tauren stark who bent the knee to my
ancestor aegon targaryen
in exchange for his life and the lives
of the northmen
tauren stark swore fealty to house
targaryen in perpetuity
or do i have my facts wrong i wasn't
there you grace
no of course not but still
an oath is an oath in perpetuity means
what does perpetuity mean lord tyrion
forever
forever so i assume
my lord you're here to bend the knee
i am not
no well that is unfortunate
you've traveled all this way to break
faith with house targaryen
break faith your father burned my
grandfather alive he burned my uncle
alive
he would have burned the seventies my
father was an evil man
on behalf of house targaryen
i ask your forgiveness for the crimes he
committed against your family
and i ask you not to judge a daughter by
the sins of her father
our two houses were allies for centuries
and those were the best centuries the
seven kingdoms have ever known
centuries of peace and prosperity with a
targaryen sitting on the iron throne
and a stark serving as warden of the
north
i am the last targaryen jon snow
honor the pledge your ancestor made to
mine bend the knee and i will name you
warden of the north together
we will save this country from those who
would destroy it
you're right you're not guilty of your
father's crimes
and i'm not beholden to my ancestors
vows
then why are you here because i need
your help
and you need mine
did you see three dragons flying
overhead when you arrived
i did and did you see the dothraki
all of whom have sworn to kill for me
they're hard to miss
but still i need your help
not to defeat cersei you could storm
king's landing tomorrow and the city
would fall
hell we almost took it and we didn't
even have dragons almost
but you haven't storm king's landing why
not
the only reason i can see is you don't
want to kill thousands of innocent
people
it's the fastest way to win the war but
you won't do it
which means at the very least you're
better than cersei
still that doesn't explain why i need
your help
because right now you and i and cersei
and everyone else
we're children playing at a game
screaming that the rules aren't fair
you told me you liked this man i do in
the time since he's met me
he's refused to call me queen he's
refused to bow and now he's calling me a
child
i believe he's calling all of us
children
figure of speech your grace everyone you
know will die
before winter's over if we don't defeat
the enemy to the north as far as i can
see you are the enemy to the north i am
not your enemy
the dead are the enemy
you